toutes les situations sont particulières
c'est vrai donc on ne peut pas définir
dès le départ une situation une action à
mener
puisque ce sera le feu sera fonction de
l'aérologie du vent de la température ça
peut être fort sur la nature du ca peut
être dans une zone herbacée ça peut dans
une zone est robuste yves et en fonction
de la nature des deux ce qui brûle
je prends l'exemple du dfe de bambou qui
est un fait assez jeu vicieux il ya la
partie visible en partie aérienne menée
à la partie souterraine par rapport aux
reason donc feu peut partir de 1 1 point
et brusquement se développer dans une
autre zone
en ayant suivi la partie soutiennent pas
forcément visibles on tourne on peut se
retrouver très facilement encerclé
bach par des femmes et c'est là la
partie dangereuse notamment si alentours
d'une habitation
vous avez des parties
riche en bambou riche en arbre en arbre
et ce sont tous ces risques avec les
flammèches qui peuvent accentuer les le
danger différent dans le nord et dans le
sud nous n'avons pas la même
configuration de tirets nous n'avons pas
les mêmes
les mêmes configurations de plantes etc
et
avec aussi l'effet de l'effet de foehn
nous avons des parties beaucoup plus
sèches eux
sur la partie nord caraïbe aussi qu'il
faut que si vous leur envoyez vous
passez sur les routes
vous voyez toute la partie du littoral
particulièrement sèche et qui à toulon
peut favoriser des départs de feu